what would you do if someone you loved
was experiencing spiritual warfare how
would you combat it well you would
certainly pray for them what else might
you do to help in this episode we'll
discuss the importance of scripture the
role of music and how confession and
repentance can help someone who is
facing a significant battle the Bible
says for we do not wrestle against flesh
and blood but against principalities
against Powers against the rulers of
Darkness of this age against spiritual
hosts of wickedness and the Heavenly
places so get ready and learn how to put
your armor
on Welcome Back Sabrina and David uh
your guys's last conversation I'm still
mulling over in my head some of the
stories that you shared um spiritual
warfare is not for the
light-hearted and I appreciate your
guys's honesty and your vulnerability in
sharing those stories I know you're
going to share a few more stories today
but I'm really looking forward to um
what what do you do about this and and
how do you have this spiritual warfare I
mean the tools are there what have you
learned and um let's hear about it so
tell us a little bit about um your work
as you got we we heard your testimony of
your wife what got you into Deliverance
Ministries and um figuring out how to
combat this spiritually um but tell us a
little bit about what happens inside of
your Bible working school cuz you've
also been confronted with this in the
bible school yeah that's right so right
after the year after uh This Is 2020 uh
Co hits um but we were still able to run
the school uh and we started just before
Co and we kind of ran it um you know in
the apartments where we were uh staying
and and you know the students came and
stayed in the apartments and we ran the
school in there uh the had started had
already started to bring people to us uh
you know I think as you become more
aware of this battle uh and as you um
decide to commit uh to serve the Lord in
this area and and he calls you to that
he will start to bring the people so we
don't actively go out to look for it uh
you know we're that's not the style of
our ministry I guess we we don't right
you know we're not running around trying
to search for demon-possessed people no
advertising you're not Exorcist at this
point you don't have a bunch of wooden
crosses in your back pocket no okay no
no so you know it's it's not something
we really look for and and it's not
something we want to look for to be
honest right um but we're committed to
serving whoever the Lord brings to us
and so right in the next year the Lord
brought a student to us who um you know
we did not realized at the time was
dealing with this and uh that began kind
of a year long back battle uh over the
year um because she came and not only
went through the Bible school but stayed
on for Bible work okay so this person
clearly wants to do God's work yes
coming into God's work having Bible
studies with you guys all the time how
do you recognize there's something not
right well this one's a very this one
was very obvious oh okay it's speaking
to you and and yeah changing the voice
tone sound yeah so the first time this
happened uh it was on the weekend uh we
weren't having class and uh they had
just come back from a social I think
this was Sunday uh so there was a social
on Sunday I think they went hiking and
uh with as an Outreach came back and in
the evening she started saying that
something was not right she did not feel
good and
um and then I think by the early evening
um she had collapsed and and um when her
uh roommates came uh she started
screaming and you know they they started
praying for her uh they called more
Bible workers um you know some of the
other Bible workers came were you there
for that first one you weren't yeah so
my brother it was the pastor at that
time came and he started praying uh and
then he called to me probably around
midnight it's about yeah 11 11 something
and and said look we need your help
you've dealt with this with your wife so
you know come over and and and and help
us with it and we went from about
midnight and this is the first time so
we're we don't know what we're doing we
just I just have the knowledge from you
know my wife being just being delivered
in November this is probably around
March uh March Yeah March period so
you're a seasoned veteran at this point
in you know how to deal with these
things are you are you like like your
heart pounding oh for sure yeah yeah so
uh he calls me around mid 11 something
now I'm flying out to Philippines uh for
work the next morning uh around I think
9 or 9 or 10 so we go all through the
night till about 6 oh my uh and at first
when he my brother called me I was like
yeah can I avoid it this time yeah yeah
yeah what you know in this situation is
there ever a no yeah you know what I
mean what's more important yeah I mean
not to say it like that I don't know you
know you might lose your job or
something like that but but seriously I
mean this is important definitely yeah
but you know there's still of course
that that fear uh you always still have
that fear when you're dealing with uh
demons I don't think we ever run in and
and go okay you let's uh yeah here we
this is fun bring out the tools exactly
so the f as soon as I walk in the door
um she had
you know they were still praying and
they were still singing scripture songs
um but uh you know she was screaming on
and off and she pauses as soon as I walk
in and she looks up at me and she says
oh you uh we left your wife and we had
to go somewhere so we're going to her oh
my and that brought chills up my spine
but at the same time uh like they know
you they recognized you for sure yeah
these other ones that you're with we
don't know him but this guy we know
David he's like Paul right sounds like a
familiar Bible story yeah right yeah so
um you know they they tried to rile Me
On by talking about my wife and that
just you know that that got me upset wow
um but you know I just as I came in the
room I just remembered what we had done
for my wife uh and um we'd kind of
written a little bit of a script so I
print out the script and uh we went
through the process of uh starting to
help her wow wow and so you know it's
interesting that you're saying this is
happening to somebody that's actively
engaged in Bible study I mean you would
you would think like the these are
people that you know are coming off of
like drugs and clubs and things like
that but this is somebody who's really
truly
honestly giving their heart over to God
maybe still struggling with things we
talked a little bit about that the other
day that's right there's still something
in there that's giving those demons an
ability to be there yeah do you know
what that was yes we do so Sabrina will
share a little bit of that but uh you
know this began the journey and it took
us about 6 hours and at least for that
first instance the Lord led us and we uh
cast out um you know quite a number of
demons from her uh and so what we did
was you know they would put her to sleep
or you know paralyze her and then we
would have to so in between all of that
we would then pray we would claim Bible
texts we would sing scripture songs we
would pray for her then we would rebuke
the demons uh and then she would come
back to Consciousness then we would ask
her to pray and ask the Holy Spirit what
with the open doors and then she would
pray and ask the Holy Spirit and then
you know the Holy Spirit would impress
her heart then she would confess and but
they were still you know other demons
would come forward manifest uh and then
take over and so this battle kind of
just went back and forth uh you know for
six hours how aware are these how aware
is she what's going on I mean is she
like oh wow that was crazy I remember
you know this and this and this was
happening or is she just waking up like
does not recall what just happened in
the last few hours uh when they put her
to sleep she does not recall she doesn't
know what's going on or if they take
over uh for her she does not for others
they do so again it's it's different for
everybody why the length of time or do
you know we don't know but the reason
why I took that long was because they
kept putting her to sleep then we would
just be praying the next demon would
manifest then we would just be praying
that God would you know and and claiming
Bible texts on Jesus and then they would
kind of step back or release their hold
in a way of her and then she would come
to Consciousness and then we would you
know uh speak to her ask her hey you
know there's other open doors still
they're still there there's more of them
and so she would continue to pray are
you essentially dealing with one by one
at that time we were yeah so we we
learned later on uh and I'll jump back
into that later um after Sabrina shares
a little bit uh eventually what we found
out at the end of it uh or what the Holy
Spirit impressed her was that they were
kind of things in the
home um almost charms that and we were
we were renting that place for the
students and somehow there were
paintings there were charms that were
left there uh that kind of became an
open door for her and then initiated
what was already in her uh and so we had
to get out of we we made the decision to
get out of that home yeah and move to
another place um and we moved the
students out of there to combine with
the lady Bible workers where they were
staying uh and that's where she started
become a housemate with Sabrina wow and
actually she was not the only one who
sensed that there's something wrong with
the house there was another girl who
sensed that something wrong I think she
also was able to see a figure in the
house yeah so it started from there and
actually it was a week be after he had
the the training or a few weeks after he
had the our first spiritual warfare
training in the class and then they just
like showed themselves and manifested
thems more to the students yeah wow are
you guys going out and like knocking on
door and having Bible studies with
people yeah I mean what what why what
would prevent this from happening like
at someone's house can you imagine that
no it doesn't yeah yeah like you're like
you know oh okay well sure you want to
come in and study the Bible and then all
of a sudden you know all hell breaks
loose sorry for the pun but literally
like why why why this setting and sort
of in your private
space well I I think it was more the
case of since the Lord had allowed you
know me and my wife to go through it he
now knew that you know and and we I made
a commitment to the Lord on this area he
now knew that he could bring people to
us uh and so over the years now you know
the Lord is the one that brings them to
us we don't actively go out to search
for it um you know that's not our desire
um but we're ready if the Lord brings
somebody to us and so every year uh
generally he will bring people to the
school who are dealing with this uh and
so there were two people in that year uh
who were dealing with this the first the
one that I just mentioned she was the
most severe case the other one was kind
of a different um the way they were
harassing her in a different way and I
don't think she was possessed uh but
they were certainly there in in a major
way in her life and we'll talk about
that in a moment but you know maybe we
can finish with
this was she
embarrassed by what was happening
I think so yeah definitely I mean it
just seems like if if if I were to
experience that you know I I think
that'd be an embarrassing moment you
know like yeah like what do I have in my
life I mean all of us probably have
something that you know we don't want
other people to know yeah and and I mean
you're out on the table yeah that's
right yeah so so yeah it definitely was
not um you know something she was proud
of or I wanted to have it discussed
openly and uh but over the months as
they kept attacking I think that became
the least of the worries and it was more
about how do I have freedom I want
freedom yeah how do I have freedom yeah
I think you come to a realization of of
look you know the the best option here
is for me to to clear this you know Y
and as she was trying to come closer to
the Lord and she actually came to Bible
work that's when they started attacking
her even more and I think the purpose of
why they started attacking more was to
discourage her right so that she would
leave you know leave Bible work she
would leave God's word and go back to
the old lifestyle but um we believe that
she God allowed her to go through that
so that she could also be a testimony to
others so that she can use that to help
more people who go through the same
problem and also to give them
encouragement and also hope that there
is a
God can deliver someone like her and God
can help people who have other severe
cases of you know possession yeah I I
think this is such an important topic
that that I think a lot of people are
unprepared to to know how to actually
handle this y um I'm so glad there's a
Ministry like what you're doing is is is
existing that you get an opportunity to
really kind of help people okay if this
is going on around you um here's what
you do about it um but um I'm I'm very
curious because she had things in the
house okay that's kind of not
everybody's case right but what was she
doing outside of that that that was
something an object or something like
this was there something in her life we
talked about in the last one yeah
unforgiveness yeah um so yeah that was
it was definitely a bunch of a bunch of
things Serina do you want to yeah share
so I guess uh it started actually from
her childhood um I guess the parents
were involved in and spiritual things
like saucery or witchcraft I not really
sure or even you know go to the fortune
telling and I guess when she was younger
that already opened up the door and the
one specific thing that the Holy Spirit
told her to remove was her earrings her
earrings that she had so after that she
that first time that she was delivered
she had to throw out a lot of stuff
bunch of makeup bunch of earrings or
jewelry and when because her earrings I
guess was blessed since she was young
yeah yeah sometimes they get an ear
piercing at like what a year under that
or whatever and it has has some kind of
significance to it yes and so the thing
that really allowed the demons to get
involved in her life was more of a
generational sin and as she was
converting and coming closer to the Lord
the demons knew that oh she's coming
closer to the Lord so we have to get a
hold of her we can't let her go so they
were were throughout her life they were
part of her and in her life and so when
she was going through a lot of
Deliverance um we figure out that there
are things that she has to throw out or
there are things that she has not
confessed or surrendered to God so as we
found found out of that you know the
demons will still keep coming if or we
found out that if they keep coming in
there's something that she has not asked
for forgiveness so asking for
forgiveness is really important and
there are times where they try to stop
her from asking God for forgiveness yeah
they can't say the words or whatever
similar to my distracting distracting
her or yeah yeah so the main point as
well is you know when you don't confess
your sins this give the demons or the
devil access and um a hold into your
life and as soon as they confess your
sins they just let go of their hold and
so when we figure out out this we you
know every time when she is going
through the deliverance we ask her that
you have you confess everything and she
would know do her personal confession
and after that you know the demons will
flee and times yeah I know this sounds
like over
simplified but God made it simple yeah I
mean to be honest like like like I
imagine even back in Moses's day when
they made the brass serpent right and it
was just like look at the thing I I
question the people that didn't look at
it like oh you all you had to do is look
at it and that would be resolved yeah
and and and you know as easy as it is
for us to get into sin I always tell
people like you know like they they they
want to have this like God's too hard
but but look he he's he's recognizing
that it's easy for us to get involved in
these awful things so he's provided easy
ways ask for forgiveness that's right
sit there and go over in your mind and
go look I'm struggling with these things
I'm sorry I got angry with my children
my dog my whatever you know I mean just
like go over your life and just ask for
forgiveness that seems like such a
simple task and yet people still refuse
to do that yeah but I I would say it
sounds simple but for somebody who's
dealing with possession
yeah uh they have an alternate
reality and so they're living in a world
that we don't understand a lot of the
time they're having thoughts they're
having feelings especially people who
have deep
Brokenness in their childhood right so
for her she grew up um you know parents
were second marriage um came out of
other marriages they were step you know
uh siblings and so it was yeah well it
was just kind of Brokenness a lot of
Brokenness so she grew up with you know
some unforgiveness in the heart and you
know as Sabrina said when she was young
uh parents brought her to I guess the
equivalent of a witch doctor or a
fortune teller as well because she was
not well and it seems to be kind of a
common practice in certain parts of uh
Asia you mentioned that it's just it's
just a cultural thing you're sick it's
kind of like going to the um Alternative
Health that's right like going to you
know the natural the the natural path so
have a question sure how do you
reconcile this idea because on the one
hand I hear okay generational sins at
the same time the child isn't choosing
that a lot of times like they're too
young to choose that like the parent is
essentially choosing for them yeah so
they could grow up and essentially
reject that not want that how do you
reconcile that idea like you're talking
about in Exodus 20 with the one let's
see it's in Ezekiel 18 where it says
the son shall not bear the guilt of the
father nor the father bear the guilt of
the son the righteousness of the
righteous shall be upon himself and the
wickedness of the wicked shall be upon
himself so it's almost like you have
two ideas in Scripture that I don't
think they conflict because I don't
think the Bible conflicts itself but how
do you reconcile those two ideas because
on the one hand it it seems like well if
the kid didn't choose that why did they
have yeah access like why can they do
something to the kid if the kid is not
making the choice for that you know what
I mean yeah yeah understand I I I think
so let's take the case of my wife mhm
she grew up seeing them sure but could
they they could never enter into her and
they could never communicate with her
yeah until she went one step further so
yeah somehow there are certain things
they can do but then there's still
certain things that they can't do um you
know they can try to lay claim but they
can't lay total claim uh unless there's
consent at some point from the child
right so they're still it's like
somebody grows up and and I've read
recently read a book by an ex
Satanist you know she was kind of
brought into uh the cult at a young age
and you could say that she was innocent
she didn't know what she was doing but
as she started to make those decisions
to give her will then that's when uh it
no longer becomes the sins of the
fathers it's really the sins of the
children now and and I think that's fair
and I think that's fair towards God I
don't think God is going to insist like
well you know your dad there did this
and so it's automatically a generational
curse and you're getting punished for it
like you have to be participatory in
that somehow or another and I think the
text if I'm if I'm thinking about it in
in Exodus alludes to that when it says
of of those that hate me like in other
words there's a an action on the
person's part right that's that happens
in those Generations yeah definitely I I
would look at it more like um propensity
to sin right so you have uh that what's
passed from one generation to another is
the greater propensity to open
yourselves up to that so look at let's
look at Abraham right Abraham lied yeah
and so did his child then you know it it
came all the way Jacob lied
y uh right to about uh you know to Isaac
and Isaac also lied about Rebecca being
his wife so there was a generational sin
or propensity greater propensity to sin
yeah passed on from each generation and
you look at David
adultery yeah his children dealt with or
he dealt with his children doing worse
weird ex man you know what I mean I hate
I hate this about the system though
because I think about like things I've
struggled with in my life and and things
that I've done wrong and it's like
please Lord don't don't don't don't
don't pass that on to my children so
question that I would have is in a
converted life you have you know a
converted Soul baptism change of life
and all that does that break
it I mean if it's a propensity like so
my view on that is if you look at
Abraham yes this is why God waited so
long to give him a child if you look at
uh John the Baptist you know all the
ones who are in general Great Men of the
Bible are filled with the Holy Spirit
they had to wait yeah they had to wait
you look at Samuel yeah Joseph you know
Hanah he only had a child later on right
once after everyone else had and then
John the Baptist so there is something
there's still a there's something
connection connected back to our DNA and
so if I want to have you know in in
answer to that question if I want to
make sure my children I'm not passing
anything on to my children then I got to
make sure that I have victory over that
and I've created a new DNA path ways New
Creation I'm a new creation and I'm
acting in I'm living the Sanctified life
before I have my children interesting
and that's you know that's the way that
the Bible shows us uh we we we
interviewed a couple from um Netherlands
and you know you brought up that um
parents will often bring a child to some
sort of like soothsayer or um fortune
teller so that they can kind of figure
out what's going on with my kid right
and um that's what opened up the door
but they did not do that with the other
children and that child actually dealt
with it whereas the other children did
not by the time they were kind of like
figured it out and converted they you
know didn't have that problem with their
with their future children but that one
they did right yeah interesting yeah so
I I think there's
multiple explanations for you know for
all of this but yeah so for her I think
you know the early stage of life was
through the Brokenness in the home
unforgiveness combined with parents had
brought her to uh Witch Doctor uh but
then as she grew
up and she started to come into the
Christian faith um she started to join
the Pentecostal movement and so she
started speaking tongues and so that
became another open door for her as well
and So speaking in tongues became a big
part of her life mhm uh and there were
times
where um you know the demons possessed
her and she would be speaking in tongues
so just for somebody listening that's
like hold on speaking in tongues is in
the Bible people did that so what are
you saying like speaking in tongues like
that doesn't make any sense because
obviously people in the Bible spoke in
different tongues so why is that a
problem I think not all speaking in
tongues is speaking in tongues in the
biblical way sure and we've certainly
seen that through a lot of the victims
spiritual warfare victims that we've
been helping and a lot do come from the
Pentecostal movement a lot do come from
you know those who are speaking in
tongues and are harassed and uh as they
pray about that the Holy Spirit convicts
them of that as well and um you know as
they change their view on what the Bible
is saying on speaking in tongues and uh
you decide to move away from that repent
of that um they're free in the Bible
when the gift of tongues was given it
was given for a specific reason it was
given so that the apostles those with
them could communicate the gospel um in
different languages to those surrounding
them it happened to be um essentially a
holiday and in Jerusalem at that time so
there were lots of visiting
Jews uh who
didn't necessarily speak the local
languages uh they spoke all kinds of
other languages because they grew up in
other places places but that gift was
poured out so that the gospel could be
communicated to them it wasn't something
that was just given so Christians could
say hey look I have the the gift of
tongue I this is evidence that I have
the Holy Spirit in fact the Bible says
that the holy spirit is given at baptism
so um that's that's when we receive the
Holy Spirit and it's not something that
is
just I want to put this carefully
it the the gifts that are given by the
Holy Spirit are given for a reason to
further God's kingdom it's never for
just like to stake a claim that hey I
have the Holy Spirit that's right yeah
to simplify even what you said just even
more it's like you speaking in English
but you're hearing it in German French
Portuguese Spanish at the same time yeah
they were known languages too you're
speaking one language and six 10 15
different language understanding like he
just said that in Portuguese no he
didn't he just said it in English but
you know what I mean it's like that
would be really super confusing and
that's why they mentioned are these guys
drunk like how is this even possible
that you're doing that and you know
that's what happened because they said
we hear in our own tongue so that's
right they were speaking whatever the
language they were speaking Greek or
whatever and then they heard in their
own language the wonderful Works God we
actually have a video we'll put it right
here is speaking in tongues if you guys
are interested in that um and of course
the C chat chat's going to blow up on
this on this topic right here but uh
look into it trust me I'm I'm sure you
guys are curious about it but anyway
yeah if I can just add you know one last
view on that I think there's two views
on the speaking in tongues one is it's
uh somebody speaking exactly as you
mentioned in their tongue and then
everybody else hearing it in their own
tongue uh but then there's other texts
you know a few other texts in First
Corinthians uh and elsewhere where
they talk about unknown tongues and so
it's debated do we is that unknown
tongue unknown to me but not unknown to
somebody else or is that uh you know the
language of angels so those are the two
views and I think if you take the view
from acts you can still explain uh 1
Corinthians but if you want to go just
into 1 Corinthians without the book of
Acts then you would explain it the other
way as well yeah and now we have chat
gp4 and we have Google trans so we don't
need
that but well anyway Spirit gave other
gifts too that was just one so it's not
the only gift that's given yes so tell
me a little bit more about this
individual you're starting to have
regular Communications about her
experiences yeah you're relaying to her
what you're seeing and you're
experiencing she's aware of this now
how's she get away from that um so right
after that first experience
and then she starts coming closer to the
Lord um like I mentioned she started
experience more of demonic harassments
and possessions almost like every week
and I became her roommate and I have
another roommate that would uh be always
you know be going up to her and praying
for her and somehow the Holy Spirit
would speak to her and tell her there's
things that you need to destroy in your
possessions in your house and she would
get that and Destroy because th those
things that she has are possessed in in
her possession is also kind of an open
door that demons could come or keep
coming in and as we keep destroying the
things and and also as she you know is
convicted to confess or Surrender those
things to God um slowly the the there
are less occurrence of the demonic
possessions or harassments that she's
facing and there's one time I remember
um she was getting ready to go to bed
and I was getting ready to go to bed too
and somehow I sensed that something was
not right in like what do you mean by
that um she seems very serious and she
was restless and she was fidgety fidgety
yes and I told her oh could you help me
turn off the lights uh so that we can go
to sleep and and I just don't feel
something is right so I got up I just
prayed and started to confess my
personal sins you know get ready to get
get to battle and so I walked to her bed
and I like hey are you okay and then she
said they're coming run so she's telling
me to run and the others and you know
there's a sense of fear at that moment
but then I I said no Jesus is here I'm
not going to run the moment I said that
it was not her anymore said she told you
to run and she got up she scream I
thankfully I got my other friends from
the other rooms to come and help her so
got her pin her down and we start um
commanding those demons to go away and
those we're still the early stages of
you know getting to know and how to do
deliverances so um when we were singing
we're claiming Bible text uh yesterday
that one other time I mentioned you know
when we were claiming and singing Bible
text the they say put down your sword
and we were singing by then you know so
we keep on claiming Bible text Bible of
the Bible text because we know that the
sword of the spirit which is the word of
God is so powerful that they did not
like to hear it and they just you know
they just keep screaming and asking us
to stop and you know how when people are
possessed you they're very strong and I
know I can't hold her down but I pray
Lord could you please hold her down for
me so and and put your Angel's hand on
her so that she will not move or try to
get away and so I was barely touching
her and she couldn't move wow yeah yes
and I wish you could see what was going
on in that moment you know what I mean
mhm and there are times where they say
why are you here you know like they're
not talking to us by it's like sorry you
know don't disturb us leave us alone we
could know we understand that you know
God's presence are his angels are there
with us as well right and and you I I
really have this question when we get to
heaven like do they know each other is
it like you know oh no not you Bob like
like you know they communicate I mean
they they lived with each other right
yeah and so you know uh or are they
unrecognizable in the state that they're
in and it's just they kind of see in two
sides you're on Satan's side or you're
on God's side and it's just there's
somebody on God's side you know that's
right but still wow yeah and also one
interesting thing you know how you
always listen in Disney movies they
always have the songs and you know
Frozen 2 right they they have the
spirit's calling out yep and it has it
was a big thing during that year and uh
we also hear it you know people singing
everywhere and that time the demons were
singing that tune and we know that they
were using that tune to call other
demons to come in to come help yeah to
come help and sometimes we have to
command them to stop doing that and even
she would be fidgeting her hands in a
way that are enforcing and calling more
demons to help strengthen you know now
that's a wild thought you know a lot of
these people that write these songs I
know that they get them from inspiration
right yes you getting inspired listening
to the tunes and putting music to those
scripture things right who's inspiring
you is that the Holy Spirit that's
saying you know this is sort of The
Melody of this thing right well I can
imagine the counterfeit version of that
is there are tunes and things that the
demons like to listen to or here or
whatever I I I always tell people too
when when talking about the topic of
music if you were to go back and listen
to a Babylonian worship ceremony I
guarantee you it's like the
VMAs I mean it's probably sounds the
same you know little riffs and tunes and
things like that I'd be like whoa that
was like Kanye West right there you know
like I guarantee you there there is a
stark difference between those two
sounds yes that's right and this is why
it's so important to guard what you
listen to yeah and she faced a lot of
other um you know exper experiences in
in the such of that case sometimes she
gets discouraged and sometimes she just
wants to give up but we have people
behind the scenes praying and
interceding for her and that I I believe
that's what is really important when
someone is dealing with possession and
harassment we' have a group of people
praying as well and interceding for now
here's a weird question um I'm a video
guy we all have video cameras in our
pockets MH is it tempting to pull out
the video camera and show people what's
going
on no you don't think about it at that
moment it's not like something like yeah
I'm going to I'm I'm going to pretty
much video this and show somebody we
have never we have never video I don't
know if that would absolutely freak you
out if you were the person that was you
know experiencing that demonic
oppression um but it just seems like you
know yeah I think when you know when
you're in the thick of it your
single-minded focus is just Lord help me
yeah and you're just you know you're
just trying to be as in tune with the
Lord as possible uh to you know really
pray and and ask for his presence to be
there and you know you feel the presence
of something that is far more Superior
to you and incites a level of fear in
your heart just by them being there you
might not be able to see them but just
the way that they're speaking through
her the way that they're inciting and
for her she was more kind of the
screaming was the one that kind of
scared everybody um we have somebody
else you know that that we've worked
with and we'll probably talk about in
the moment is for her they took over and
there was a multitude of voices and they
would all just be at the same attacking
not at the same time but you know they
would just switch and they would just
just be criticizing you and attacking
you and you know just trying to demean
you uh you know and that that was a
different approach uh to the this person
that we're talking about she was a lot
more kind of aggressive and screaming
and struggling um but the other one
would be with her mouth to try to really
put fear in your heart and try to kind
of get you to the point where man I
don't want to deal with this I just want
to get up get away from this is that
something she dealt with in her own life
like she was just critical of other
people yeah yeah definitely yeah so that
that was something that she kind of grew
up with or just you know it had become a
part of nature but if I can just add to
what Sabrina said so that e that night
when they came uh you know we we
probably did it about 10 to 10 to 15
times throughout that year uh they would
call me and I would drive over sometimes
in the middle of night as I was coming
close to the house she would start to
scream and say I don't want him you know
get get rid of him don't let him in wow
I hate him you know and they would she
would just start screaming like I'd be
like maybe a mile away uh before I got
there and she would start screaming out
to them as they're holding her down or
you know trying to rebuke the demons
they would the demons literally would
start to say I hate that I hate that
that's a great YouTube video title like
demons hate this
guy yeah you know what I mean John
Constantine you got nothing on this
guy you don't engage with them though
you take the Jesus approach you don't
talk to them you don't communicate with
them we command them you command them
yeah we command them but we're
definitely not but if they're like
trying add an argument to you or
belittle you or whatever you're not
you're not we ignore that and we just
command them to keep silent or we
command them you know we we claim Bible
texts and and command them so it's all
about more of commanding them um but
definitely we're not trying to you know
have a conversation with them right
Jesus clearly did but they're trying to
have a conversation with us of course
yeah so they're really trying to needle
you they want to you into conversation
that's right yeah so you know and yeah
so that would be something that um you
know would often happen uh and and for
me that year was really about I just
fresh from you know what they' done to
my wife and so I was just all into you
know I'm I'm out to get back at you I'm
I'm out for you know to to avenge what
you've done by helping you know somebody
else and so that was this just great
determination to deal with it never as
the years have pass it's become more of
H I wish I didn't have to deal with it
but I will because I've committed to the
Lord um but that year was just real
determination I think they knew that you
know and and that's why they hated me so
much so you know when I arrived it was
you know really all out you know let's
get rid of them and let's let's pray and
ask God for help but we are not leaving
till we get R rid of them you know and
so so they knew that determination that
I had um and there was another time
where we were doing a Deliverance for
her um they took
over and they spoke to us that were
there and they said we hate you guys we
hate the work that you're doing and
we're going to destroy
you and then she rushed at me and it was
just as if there again there was a wall
there and she just hit the wall like
there's nothing in between us it's like
me and you and then she just rushes at
me uh while she's possessed and and then
she just stops because she couldn't move
any further uh you know and so all of
these experiences helps us to realize
that we have nothing to fear right if
our life is right with the Lord if we
confess our sins before we go into
battle the Lord is the one fighting that
battle and if they try anything
aggressive or you know anything else
that uh they try to do um you know that
there's an angel between them there's an
angel of the Lord between them and us
all the time I think this is a really
important thing because as I'm sitting
here listening to you I'm kind of
thinking about either a portrayal that
I've seen in the movies they always talk
to them and I think almost like you know
like like movies to me are are just like
behavioral modeling right you see
somebody else do it and then when you
get into that situation uh this is how
you act right and if they're always
engaging and having communication and
wanting to get some sort of information
out of them or whatever like that what
you're basically doing to your audience
is you're teaching them you need to
communicate with these people and I
think it's very important that you don't
communicate with them there is a wo it
is not the battle is not between you and
them yeah the battle is between them and
God yes it's essentially becomes their
word over God's word you know when
you're I think if you're engaging in
conversation what do they want to do
they want to lie mhm it's essentially
what they want to do they want to lie no
point in talking to somebody who's just
constantly lying and and they want to
fill your mind with lies so that you'll
become discouraged or upset or or
whatever about the situation and so it's
about God's word versus their word
what's more important God's word's more
important that's the word we listen to
yeah yeah now having said that though
you do need to get to a point where you
know what the open doors are yeah uh
and there's one way uh the more
Pentecostal way where you know they
where they deal with um uh casting out
of demons where they do command the
demons to speak their legal rights uh
and and to share what it is that is
their legal rights um so we kind of that
was something that we did learn in the
beginning we read about um but over the
course of time as we've done this we uh
as you said they will lie so you can
tell them to mhm speak the truth in the
name of Jesus but they'll still lie so
so if you're asking them what's your
stronghold they could be lying to you
yeah yeah so so you we've we've you know
we we've stopped doing that and really
what we do is again just engage with the
Holy Spirit the holy spirit to guide the
individual and US sometimes the
impression will come to us sometimes the
impression will come to the person uh
the victim and uh they will know what
they need to confess yeah sometimes it
takes many days you're appealing to the
victim not the entity we're appealing to
the Holy Spirit um to impress upon the
victim um but they will try to stop that
as well right so thus that six hours or
long periods of time where they're
putting them to sleep they're strangling
them they're keeping them silent um you
know there's there's many things that
they try to do to discourage them from
wanting to go through this process um
the other thing I would mention also is
that you know back to the question of
it's so simple for them to just confess
why don't they do it um because many
times they're living in as I said in
this world um you know of uh of reality
alternate reality and so one of the
things that you know we have to do is
counsel with them and say I know that
you think that's real but you can punch
through that illusion so it's almost a
smoke screen and there's an illusion
that they're living under mhm um you
know and and maybe we can move on to
another person that uh you know we were
counseling with um
she she she was not possessed but she
had lived for S years uh you know and
this was all happening during the
pandemic as well uh and you know she was
also one of our Bible workers she had
lived for seven years with the knowledge
that um so she had uh a pregnancy out of
wedlock had an abortion and then um you
know for 7 years she thought that God
was punishing her and there was a um a
consequence of her actions and so she
had this heaviness in her heart almost a
crushing pain uh and every so often when
she saw children she would cry for weeks
and it just be this anxiety this
crushing pain upon her that just sat
there the guilt the guilt yeah the guilt
the shame but you know when we started
to counsel with her and it wasn't you
know again the Lord just brought about
that conversation because you know we we
just finished helping some you know the
the girl that we just talked about with
deliverance and then you know uh we were
just going around the circle any you
know any Brokenness we need to know
about any before we go into another
deliverance and and then she start open
up and it took us 3 weeks to talk
through that counseling multiple times
to help her to realize this is not a god
of love if he's as a consequence of
forgiveness you have this pain uh you
know and and she'd been living with this
reality though for seven years and every
time you know she every time she saw a
child that pain would come and she would
just cry and that was just her life that
was just reality for her but as we
counseled over about three 3 weeks she
learned to start to rebuke that and say
no that's not my identity and uh you
know and then she claimed Bible texts
that showed that Jesus loved her she was
a child of God you know 1 John 3:1 um
you know behold what manner of love um
the father is this that he made us the
sons of God yeah right and so he and she
started claim this and claim this and
claim this until the
text overcame her current reality and so
this is why it's so hard for those who
are dealing with you know not just
possession but sometimes harassment that
fear of I feel the pain you know this is
not fake but you're telling me that I
don't have to feel the pain it's like
it's like um one of the problems with
the Human Condition I guess the
perpetuation of sin is that we continue
to believe the lies of the Enemy versus
the word of God that's right and and
getting back to reality is when we can
get back to believe that God's word is
true yeah but the thing is when we
believe those lies it gives them uh the
permission in a sense to then make the
feelings or the pain that accompanies
that lie right and so part of the
counseling uh and and helping those who
are dealing with this is to help them to
see I know you feel it's real I know you
feel the feeling that it is real um but
it is a lie and you can punch through
this smokes screen with the word of God
you can pierce it with the word of God
and so as you start to claim the texts
that are relevant and and you know she's
also somebody who came through the Bible
school was fervent committed into Bible
work is now in Ministry and the Lord is
helping her to deal with that now M yeah
so this is not somebody's jumped off the
deep end doing drug Dr alcohol right you
know right which is so crazy I know we
deal with this in our country we just
don't see it in that way yeah you know
yeah even in Malaysia people are in
witchcraft all the time out here I mean
you just you know we just crossed over
Halloween um recently and you can see on
social media how many Christians were
advocating this is a Christian holiday
yeah and you're just like what although
then the Reformation but you know what I
mean it's just like like such a strange
thing that they would advocate for that
yeah just on that note actually
something I didn't mention in the last
session uh on October 31 they woke my
wife up that night she wasn't delivered
yet and she woke up in a panic that
night and she said the witches are
flying around our condominium and
they're calling me and telling me to go
out to join them and so she was in fear
and you know anxiety and she could hear
them reaching and they were flying
around the building and uh there is this
myth that is quite possibly a reality in
Sabah with her tribe the witch The
Witches what happens on certain times of
the month is the demons will come and
detach their head from the rest of their
body and so and they fly around with
their head and their spine holding uh
you know the broomstick and they're
flying around uh and that's what she saw
oh wow you know and and they were
calling to her to come out to jump out
jump off and and join them and they they
were saying you belong to us you belong
to us wow so we had to pray and I got my
brother on the phone and him and I were
praying for her and uh finally it
subsided I made a significant
lifechanging decision when I lived in
Hollywood I was a bartender and the very
last night that I ever bartended at the
club was October oober 31st wow and I
was I would not be surprised if I was
not possessed I mean literally like it
was a drug infused fueled angry
everybody's wasted kind of a thing and
uh I went told my bosses um the day
before that night and said this will be
the last night that I actually work and
so I I I hate that day just because I I
just to me it's it's a bad significance
in my mind but but I saw those kinds of
you know not not not say manifestations
but like almost how people acted very
evil on that day yeah yeah and it's
really sad that you know so many
Christians don't realize how
powerful uh spiritually Spirit Doc and
spiritually that is that day yeah yeah
so it's um but yeah that reminded me of
that story so you have you know this
other individual that you're kind of
dealing with this as well I mean is this
kind of like these people are aware of
your ministry now and they're coming to
you or is this just happen to be like
these are just students that have or do
you meet these people who are kind of in
a worldly State and you know a good plan
to get them out of that is to involve
them in God's work and so you're kind of
sending them through that
channel um well part of it is coming
through the Bible school yeah uh and the
Lord just knows who needs to come and
and we counsel with them uh and and many
of them experience Freedom some of them
actually don't experience Freedom until
they get out into Bible work um so you
know they're struggling All Through the
Bible School uh you know the the four
and a half months and then as they go
into Bible work then we start to work
closely more intimately with them and uh
you know then they experience Victory
there uh so one channel is a Bible Bible
school another channel is just churches
around the area have heard mhm that
we're willing to help and so they they
just send everyone to us wow uh you know
and um you know we we don't we're not
going to reject anyone that comes to us
so they know and so one channel is you
know just other churches in the area
just kind of have heard another channel
is as I mentioned um uh we have helped
some people from Pentecostal uh churches
and and they you know speak in tongues
and as they have had Victory they to
share it with others and they just
continuously bring other friends that
they're meeting with uh to us or other
denominations as well so you know demon
possession pervades all religions all
denominations uh you know the demons AR
picky no yeah they're not distinguishing
what what what religion you are that's
right yeah so you know we we help
whoever the Lord however the Lord brings
and uh whoever the Lord brings to us so
how do you do that what's the
mechanics yeah so the first time we sit
down with them it's
really uh praying and asking the Lord
what are their open doors and so you
know we we sit down and we C with them
step one yeah step one is really sitting
down of course having a period of uh
prayer yeah Step Zero is you confessing
before you get to this space but yeah
yes yes uh having the prayer you know
prayer time where we are confessing uh
we're asking for you know the Lord to be
with us asking for the angels of heaven
to be sent to be with us uh and then we
go into the counseling session and as we
do that we're just keenly praying and
listening for the Holy Spirit to prompt
us what are the areas of their lives
that would have caused open doors and
because we've spoken to so many people
already who kind of have an idea you
know there's kind of major hot areas
usually childhood trauma um usually
sexuality sexual AB or some sort of
abuse um especially for the ladies um
you know and then broken homes MH uh
unforgiveness of some sort um and then
occult stuff have they been involved so
we're just probing but generally we're
letting them tell their story first and
as they tell their story the holy spirit
will guide us and you know then we ask
probing questions to understand more uh
for those who are dealing with Legion of
demons you know uh like the girl that we
told you about yesterday the other
session um you know she she came to us
and you know from the age of five she
was possessed and um you know there was
a period of time where she was led into
a marriage ceremony with Lucifer uh you
know and so Legions of demons have
inhabited her so you know over the years
we are slowly finding out bit by bit the
Holy Spirit prompts her you know God
knew that she probably couldn't handle
trying to get rid of them all at once or
it probably would just take it would be
you know too long and we we've certainly
tried we've I've gone for 16 hours one
time you know with her through the night
into the next day uh We've since learn
better then cuz you don't want to be
exhausted no you don't yeah and and
that's their primary P purpose to
exhaust you to frustrate you to get you
to give up on them uh yeah so you know
for her we realized that you you know
there's so many demons there that you
know the Lord knows in his time how to
prompt her and uh and to deal with
certain situations and you know actually
only just recently um you know she dealt
with some as we learn more from a book
that we read by an ex Satanist on other
types of open doors um you know that she
had experienced um but we didn't know
about so we can Counsel on that so we're
constantly learning as well as the Holy
Spirit uh you know as we cooperate with
the Holy Spirit on how to counsel them
is there a danger that these entities
will jump jump ship s to say everyone
always is scared of that I was scared of
that before to be honest with you uh and
everyone's always scared of that story
right the sons of ska uh having the the
demons jump into them yeah so my my my
response to that usually is look if the
demons could jump into you now they
would not wait for you to meet a Dem of
possessed person we did talk about that
the last time that's actually a
brilliant way yeah that g that gave me a
lot of like Comfort actually I was like
yeah you're right they don't need that
exact specific uh situation to happen so
what you know why can they do that is
when you know you have unconfessed sin
or you know the holy spirit's prompting
you to deal with something you're not
dealing with it and you're going in
there with your own
self-confidence uh and they're going to
teach you a lesson because you're not
protected right but that's so they beat
him up and send him home naked yeah such
a weird story isn't that a weird story
it is a strange story but but it I think
it really
demonstrates you know from a spiritual
perspective it's like you think about it
like they send them away you know their
tails between their legs and they're
naked right you think about that from
a I don't want to make it all
spiritualized and symbolic but but
essentially they they don't have that
robe of righteousness right it's like
they're without a covering that's right
like because they've they've encountered
these other beings they didn't succeed
and and what is it going to leave them
yeah right and that's how Satan wants to
leave all of us right it's like from the
very beginning you have what is Satan
always trying to do he's always trying
to uncover God's people what is God
trying to do he's trying to cover
everybody up right the very first
experience that we have that we
recognized was nakedness mhm and the
imagery in the end of the Bible is God
covering you so that you do not expose
your nakedness it's a message to Le oia
you know you need to be covered you're
naked you don't realize it yeah so for
for her um you know there were just so
many demons that it really took an
extended amount of time um but generally
you know you kind of get a good idea for
somebody who's not dealing with so many
demons uh you know in that one or two
counseling sessions and then it becomes
the Battle of fighting their alternate
reality mhm claiming Bible texts uh
remembering to claim Bible texts because
for them it's so normal right so you
know that pain um you know in in our
friend's heart um that she kept for
seven years that was just normality it
had become normality so asking her to
refuse that identity and to rebuke it in
the name of Jesus to claim Bible text
against it she would just forget and
that's kind of why it took you know she
she sincerely forgot uh and when she REM
remembered then she would rebuke it and
she would pray and uh you know command
the demons to leave and then it would
literally go away is that where one of
the ideas for um music vers to came up
with so that you would remember it uh
the word of God yeah yes definitely that
was that was kind of the thought process
behind let's let's start something that
we can sink in our mind like the ABC
song song right everybody one of us
learns the ABCs ABCD EFG right so you
learn the Bible text to those little
hymns and tunes and things yeah in there
yeah yeah and the Holy Spirit brings it
to our minds the more you sing it so if
we're singing it for church we're
singing it outside of church we're
singing it in our homes uh you know it
just that starts to become our reality
and the Holy Spirit starts to take away
that alternate reality that the demons
are creating you know and and we've
lived with for many years and this is
the same not just for possession you
know this is the same if we're dealing
with anger this is the same if we're
dealing with um you know uh fear fear or
lust or you know
Pride mhm yeah and interestingly there
is a demon of yeah there is and there
I've dealt with someone who always says
you know I want to kill myself you know
I'm not worth living and I have the
reminder that is not your thought right
you don't you're not born yourself right
yeah and so you have to rebuke that
thought that is not your thought you
have to rebuke that Spirit of and once
you did it it would go away yeah in fact
we have a um psychological button inside
of us that's called the preservation of
life and it is amazing what the human
body will do to try and survive um it's
sort of like a default mode you know you
get you get banged up or you get
whatever and your body just goes into
this like I need to survive mode and so
it's countering that it's not God's plan
Jeremiah 29:11 says God's plan is to
give us a future mhm
a future implies life right that's right
so suicides and are the answer yeah so
you you um ask for confession you begin
to you know draw out of them this
process of is there is there something
that you have in your life then what do
you do yeah so sorry just rewind a
little bit normally I start with my
testimony so that it gives them Comfort
I know what they're going through uh and
and lays a level of credibility so that
works for me then after that we you know
this is after prayer and then we go into
counseling as we hit individual spots I
don't wait till the end of counseling
right on the spot you know if uh if an
Open Door is made obvious I I hate that
person I I can't forgive them uh then I
tell them that's that's a very powerful
Open Door uh and you know you need to
confess this if you want to be free do
you want to be free and they confirm
they want to be free then we kneel
together and they will confess on the
spot and as they confess after they
finish confessing I will claim a Bible
textt possibly Zechariah 3:2 um you know
or you know other other Bible text and
then I will command the demon to leave
and because they have confessed they
will have to leave do you ever deal any
with
any non- genuine
confession definitely uh but it's not so
much what's more common is not that it's
non- genuine it's that they don't
understand
um how to confess or what they're
confessing or they haven't they haven't
dealt with it hasn't you know really
reach their heart and and a level of
understanding about what they're
confessing yet and they might just
confess
generally um but uh there you know they
come back uh and so what you know the
other part uh that I cover in my uh
training my training at the Bible school
is um unbelief is the enemy of
Faith so if you're
confessing and you don't really believe
that God's going to get rid of that or
you don't really you don't really
believe that God can you can let that go
so unforgiveness right is is very
powerful for somebody who's dealt with
abuse um you know or just has that
General habit of falling into uh you
know unforgiveness telling them that you
can forgive and God gives you that
forgiveness to give to somebody else you
don't have to even forgive on your own
strength that forgiveness just as the
faith of Jesus comes from Jesus the love
of Jesus comes from God forgiveness
comes from God as well right and that's
a very foreign concept and may take a
number of weeks or months and through
many experiences God may have to help
them to navigate multiple you know
situations for it to finally click do
you find that
people more or less project their own
issues on God so for example the
unforgiveness like I don't want to
forgive somebody therefore God would
never forgive me yeah you know or I'm so
angry at this person therefore God must
be angry at me yeah you know that kind
of thing oh definitely yeah that's
that's one of the
most powerful thoughts that's embedded
in their mind so there was another
student that came through the Bible
School um he hated his father MH and
so um his father was Muslim he grew up
in um his father was Muslim mother was
Christian he grew up you know with two
religions but he followed his mom um but
he just you know he he hated his father
I guess his father had been strict with
them um you know disciplining them and
so he had this fear and a demon had come
in the demon of unforgiveness had come
in every time he heard the mosque there
would be a deep fear within his heart
and he just like he was just paralyzed
he didn't know what to do with himself
so as we counseled I helped him you know
in the the Holy Spirit rather helped him
to see that what he thought of his
father uh and how he had dealt with him
his father had experienced it from his
father and before his father so part of
the counseling is also helping them to
empathize and realize that yeah the
person who's doing it to you is a victim
from the previous generation and this is
what we call generational sins yeah it's
being perpetuated they hate what they're
doing to you but they can't help it
because by beholding they became changed
you know and that's why a lot of young
girls who are sexually abused when
they're young they grow up to be
prostitutes yeah even though they hate
what's happened to them they just can't
help you know it's become that ingrained
in their their identity yeah they just
gravitate toward probably the demon of
forgiveness you can't change you're this
you're that you know yeah yeah so you
know we we definitely deal with that and
so a lot of counseling is helping to
realize that God is a god of love even
when you were dealing with this God is a
god of love why was he a god of love
because the demon would have loved to
destroy you and kill you at that moment
but God preserved you long enough for us
to meet and that now the healing will
come yeah right but um you know the god
in his wisdom knew the right time and
you know there were experiences
unfortunately that you had to go through
which we don't know why until we get to
heaven but God was still there yeah I've
heard people say you know our we we
spend what's what is it we spend
um after the first seven years we spend
the rest of our life basically trying to
resolve what happened in resolve you
know what what mistakes our parents made
in the first seven years or whatever
because of whatever baggage that they
had and it's and it's so true people are
people and they have you know you may
look at your abuser or whatever but as
an
abuser but they also
are you know dealing with issues just
like you are and it's it can be
difficult to see somebody like that
from like in the way that you see
yourself or the way that God sees them
well the de we want to you know project
on them like they're evil they you know
I don't like them you we want to put on
them all the all the the guilt and the
shame and and the weight of
transgression upon them yes but really
God's dealing with them too trying to
woo them trying to heal them trying to
bring them to the repentance and
forgiveness and all that it's hard it's
hard to get to that spot really is yeah
well it is it is almost impossible um
because the demons are there to
reinforce that thought or or create that
thought and then reinforce it and we
need the Holy Spirit to intercept and it
takes somebody sitting down to explain
that and so once I explained it to him
uh you know and and the Holy Spirit was
able to help him to see that he broke
down he cried and uh you know he
completely changed his perspective and
started to pray for his dad uh and then
the Holy Spirit started to bring the
memories back to him that his dad was
not as bad as he thought him thought he
was and the demons had just gotten him
to focus on one event or two events of
the life um but there were so many other
you know great memories he had of his
father forgotten um because the demons
had taken it away yeah if we hold on to
Hur it's like we we it's a way of
justifying our own anger and resentment
and all of that that's right instead of
just go this is a really important part
because I'm thinking like who who who of
us doesn't have daddy issues right yeah
I mean you know I think there's a lot of
times that people have this rocky
relationship and I've just been praying
to God like Lord help my help help my
relationship with my children to be
different or whatever but but I think
that this is really important to
consider that's the Demonic World
focusing on a few things that they are
literally getting to try and shape your
ideas about that but if you really sit
down and think about it if I sit down
and think about it and and I think very
positively about some experiences that
I've had with my dads you know and it's
like yeah did I just focus on those evil
moments or the bad parts or whatever you
know and it's like um I'm not I'm not
I'm not giving an excuse I think there's
very valid reasons why and that's
probably a whole another you had some
Bible text did you want to move into
those yeah yeah so um I think just to
close uh want to share the weapons that
we can that God has made available to us
as we become aware of the spiritual
warfare that is around us and how to
fight that both individually or helping
somebody else so I'm just going to go
through some quick um points y
so really uh there's eight points and
there's probably more as well but these
are the eight that we kind of you know
counil people with the first is the name
of Jesus uh the armor of God the sword
of the spirit the blood of Jesus uh
prayer personal testimony praise and
singing so I'm just quickly going to
show some Bible texts uh if we talk
about the name of Jesus there's many
Bible texts um probably the one that I
really want to highlight are Colossians
3:1 17 do all All In The Name Of The
Lord Jesus so as we fight as we pray as
we command the demons it's very
important to command them in the name of
Jesus because we have no Authority
whatsoever to command demons and so we
must always remember as we are
commanding them to leave commanding them
that to be silent commanding them to
release their hold of an individual we
do it in the name of Jesus uh and then
Philippians chapter 2 verse 99-1 really
important at the name of Jesus every
knee should bow of things in heaven and
things in Earth and things under the
Earth so so you're reminding them that's
right like this is your commander that's
right yeah yeah and we're calling on the
name of Jesus to command them yeah so we
can command them only in the name of
Jesus yeah important part I used to um
uh when I first started in Ministry I
when I would pray um I would just say
amen and and and somebody called me out
on that and was like you know you really
ought to pray in the name of Jesus
definitely and you know there's power in
that name that's right I believe so yeah
so next Point um well it's still in
under uh the first point so because
there's power in the name of Jesus when
we rebuke the demons we rebuke them in
the name of Jesus and Jesus himself told
us that in my name shall they cast out
Devils or in Acts 16:18 I command thee
in the name of Jesus Christ to come out
of her when uh Paul is um you know
casting out a demon uh so if we put
these texts together you know Jesus gave
us the authority to say Satan or your e
or evil spirits I rebuke you in the name
of Jesus um you know if they do ignore
us then we need to search our hearts or
continue to claim other Bible texts uh
which is the next two weapons right so
if we're rebuking a demon in the name of
Jesus they're refusing to leave there's
probably two reasons um either you have
UNC confessed sin and praise God they
haven't jumped into you or the
individual is still holding on to
something either they don't understand
what they need to let go of um or they
are knowingly resisting um so I had a I
had a funny story um you know from the
lady in Australia that counseled us uh
and and guided you know for my wife's
Deliverance she said that there was one
time she was going for weeks trying to
help this individual to cast out the
demon and she was praying and praying
praying why Lord why are they not coming
out and finally the you know the Lord
impressed her to go and speak to the the
man and say
what are you not what are you not giving
up you know why are you not wanting you
say you want to be free from the
harassment but you're not accepting
Jesus uh and you're not allowing Jesus
to get rid of them and he's like okay
full
transparency I am on um I'm being paid
by the government because I have a
mental illness and if I get rid of the
mental illness or if I have I get rid of
the Demons then the government's going
to stop pay me oh wow and I my welfare
check right I'm I was trying to think of
the name and so he didn't want Jesus to
fully make him free he there was a fear
in heart because then he would have to
work oh wow and he Lov at least you
recognize that that's a good step that's
true that's true but you know then she
said well come back when you're ready to
when you're ready to work when you're
ready to really allow Jesus to get rid
of them wow yeah so next one is the
armor of God uh you know we know
Ephesians 6:1 put on the whole armor of
God that you may be able to stand
against the Ws of the devil so every day
we have to put on the armor of God uh
what is the armor of God if we read
through Ephesians 6 it is the word of
God in every aspect of our life um you
know whether in our mind our hearts what
we eat um you know our bellies uh where
we go right and so the word of God has
to direct every part of our life and so
if we're not fully surrendering and
asking God to arm us with the AR of God
and part of that is remembering the word
of God as well memorizing scripture yeah
right so that's how we can arm ourselves
uh and that's protection right so every
day as we do our devotions um that
became very real to my wife to me to my
children that every day we need to pray
for God's protection and we need to
study the word of God and hide it in our
hearts because that is a protection but
conversely um the word of God is also an
offense it's not just a protection it is
an offense so when we're doing
Deliverance it becomes an offense um you
know when the devil is attacking you can
attack him back too right and when he's
um giving us pain we can attack him with
the sword of truth and so when somebody
is possessed the way that we go in the
offensive to attack the demon that is um
you know taking over that person and put
them to sleep or whatever it is to
resist the Deliverance is to quote
scripture right and the sword of the
spirit is the word of God and how do we
quote that scripture we love to read
Bible texts about the name of Jesus
about the power of Jesus about his
position in heaven the demons hate that
you know and literally it feels like
we're cutting them with every text that
we're saying about Jesus and so that's
how it is a sword uh the blood of Jesus
we need the blood of Jesus to cover us
um and it says in Romans 12:11 they
overcame him by the blood of the lamb
and so when we confess our sins we have
to pray for the blood of Jesus to cover
us so that when the demons look at us
we're perfect because we're covered by
the blood of Jesus and nothing for them
to call out oh wow right and so you know
I used to have a fear going in uh you
know to a Deliverance what happens if
the demon starts calling out our sins
that's happened before I've heard
stories of that and actually in one of
our deliverances uh one of the Bible
workers the demons actually started
calling out their sins um because we
were doing Deliverance for this lady the
first one that we were talking about
um there was you know after a while with
all the deliverances the ladies in the
house started to have some resentment
and some unforgiveness and some anger
towards her uh and so as we went into
the Deliverance the demon started to
point out you know she's she hates me
she's angry with me um you know she's
got unforgiveness and just started
listening it out and we had to ask her
to confess at that moment and uh and and
leave the room wow because we couldn't
do the Deliverance right wow yeah so
having the blood of Jesus is a very
important protection uh prayer of course
learning how to pray a lot of us know
how to pray um you know General prayers
or you know prayers for ourselves uh of
protection but many of us don't know how
to claim promises in prayer and that's
even more powerful and so that's
something that we've learned to do um
you know as we have over time yeah uh
done more Deliverance the Lord just
impresses us you got to use this text
and you got to claim this text as a
protection or as a offense yeah but you
got to put it in the mind otherwise it's
not going to be called the mind yes yes
that's right um personal testimony uh
Revelation 1211 you know not only did
they overcome him by the blood of Jesus
but also by the word of their testimony
and so we need to share this uh
testimony right of how God has delivered
us or how God has helped us and that
also helps us to um our minds right and
and I can imagine because of the war in
Heaven There was a lot of interactions
between the Angels right the good angels
are like pleading with the with the
angels that are making this choice and
this decision right and they just
disregarded it and went their way in
that's what how they really got
separated right so testimony of what God
has done to turn their life around is a
standing rebuke to those those that did
not choose
that never thought of it that way but
yes uh and then praise um so this is
very interesting as well you wouldn't
think that praise is a weapon um but
actually it is especially for those who
are possessed a lot of times they're
dealing with depression they're dealing
with suicidal thoughts right and so how
do you counter those negative powerful
thoughts from demons you got to counter
it with um praise uh praise to God
praise for how God is helping them
looking at the positive side of the
situation and those thoughts are coming
from God and you know there's uh I came
across this quote which which I thought
was really uh putting into this you know
it says to praise God in fullness and
sincerity of heart is as much a duty as
is prayer these exercises drive back the
power of Satan uh and so as we praise
God you know and certainly we have many
Praises in the Psalms as we claim the
Psalms and we praise God and we think of
the things we ought to praise God it
drives away the demon of depression you
know and that helps the counter as well
and then finally singing singing is
connected back to the armor of God and
putting Bible verses uh you know in our
minds and it's just another channel uh
for that but uh the demons do hate
certain hymns like Power in the Blood
sound the battlecry and certainly
scripture songs that we have on music
verse uh singing that often especially
as somebody's starting to deal with uh
or starting to become aware that they're
dealing with spir spiritual warfare uh
you know arming your mind with scripture
is so important and singing that is the
easiest way we found to memorize yeah I
got a really practical real quick um as
we're closing up a friend of mine um he
has a Bible School in um Brazil and they
had a girl that had come in and was
acting out they thought it was strange
at first and then completely was
possessed and rolling around on the
floor and screaming and all this kind of
stuff he didn't know what to do about it
and um so he called his family in there
and each one of them has instruments and
they just started getting their
instruments and they started playing and
it completely left and so you know it's
like you hear these stories of David
playing that for Saul asking a spirit to
leave and you know music is literally a
powerful way to deal with it so yes um
thank you guys for coming by what a
blessing um I thank you so much Sabrina
for um joining us I know you're you're
you're on on an airplane right here so
um thank you for your time and uh we
look forward to hearing a little bit
more um but if you guys want man check
out music verse it is a beautiful way to
learn about um uh how to commit
scriptures to your mind and um if you
just want to communicate with David
we'll put his uh uh Communications in
the description below so that you guys
can reach out to him I'm sure if you are
dealing with this or you know somebody
that's dealing with this please share
this video with somebody um and uh pray
for these guys this is a much needed
Ministry all right thank you thank you
guys for watching like And subscribe bye
if you like this video like subscribe
and hit the notification Bell so you
know when we launch new videos and drop
a comments below and we'll try to get
back to you if we can
what say that again no no I don't know
what to say
[Music]